Ace through H3 the Creator Ethan Klein
has been suspended off YouTube for
saying this comment about Ben Shapiro at
least they start rounding up the Jews
again I hope Ben gets gassed first
actually we always gonna support jokes
but I think this guy is like one of
those guys that does not allow people to
have context when he's out there
criticizing them now it's biting him in
the ass let's say if he wasn't a person
like that is that okay to say if you're
a Jewish person can you make that joke
you just don't really throw Holocaust
jokes at each other though here's the
weird thing people are like celebrating
even getting taken down but be careful
what you celebrate like I would never
celebrate this because I don't want a
joke of mine to cause our page to come
down so I cannot celebrate this and I
get it if you're annoyed by Ethan's
content he does a lot of gotcha I don't
think that like he's necessarily like an
expert in anything per se outside of
being hated by people and it not
seemingly affecting him but at the same
time if you don't have a skill set for
entertainment outside of that that's
what you're going to need to lean into
you can get a lot of views but you're
gonna continue to behave it to do so